hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast a keynote presentation
solid-phase microextraction new
developments in bio analysis and medical
applications it is presented by Barbara
Boyko PhD who is an associate professor
at nicholas copernicus university in
torun poland and Janusz polishin PhD
who's a professor of chemistry at the
university of waterloo in ontario canada
I am Judy O'Rourke of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab Ruth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speakers will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on a
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Boyko and dr.
publishin I will now turn the
presentation over to them thank you very
much for the kind introduction so I will
be talking first
my name is the inspirational mr. Wardle
I was introduced and my part of my
presentation will focus on fundamentals
just to give you an idea why the
technology works and what the
fundamentals of the technology
though when you look at this
presentation you cut you need to have
open mind because we'll be changing
paradigm also present way of doing
chemistry there specifically sample
preparation now I'll try to explain you
something which might be difficulty
difficult to you this is all six micro
extraction which you might not practice
therefore it's difficult but I'll try to
make it as simple responsible the
pointer the opportunity to improve
understanding the technology by the
ankles again the ideal think out onto
the boss what you do presently is not
necessary the most part in the science
move forward and therefore you need to
consider options focus on preparation as
he understand most of you attract
Tichenor Zanka chemistry so you
understand that this is the process the
process consists of several steps though
I'll focus on the area of several
preparations ideal sample contention
would facilitate sampling scheme does
requires very effective coupling between
the sampling sample preparation and
cooking introduction the saturation
declines touches the photograph of the
recognizer to plan a trip traditionally
and many of you probably consider sample
preparation is an art not a science
however the progress in science allows
us to look much more carefully on
different processes on clearing in
addition to preparation and therefore
you know you can actually have a full
understanding which we are doing
selection rationally optimize the
process to be very effective and by
doing so of course you have a lot of
advantages I understand many of you are
working in print
or industry one had the time to spend on
that of course I work in academia I had
opportunity to work as a young scientist
but we can make in scientific projects
and therefore that the depth of
understanding and by doing so we can
make it interesting as possible so if
you look at the subjects and even as you
will see you can look at the very
difficult sentence very interesting
information about the system so
basically the choice of your central
Federation which allow you to write the
amount of information you're going to
get and of course many of you which I am
a concern about the environment so
anytime you consider a new area of
sample preparation technology you need
to consider the technology which are
real nature meaning organic solvents in
eliminating agents the measurement on
site
and in vivo to facilitate measurements
directly with the central is we don't
need to transpose a sample to the
laboratory which justices energy
consumed instead so it's not only
elimination solvent that also moving the
chemistry inside basically comes on the
screen on second nicest some cases like
medical laboratories is very important
because giving information to the doctor
or surgeons about the condition of the
patient now of course I'll be talking
about extraction so just remind you
about the very fundamental process
process of partitioning yes if you cover
for example settlement in contact with
the extraction phase and the lights
partition extraction phase if you choose
it's dashing phase because higher
affinity towards the analyte and some
probation so you basically have this
enrichment factor K which is listed
below which is basically ratio of
concentrations at the low concentration
so you basically have a process of
increasing to consider
enrichment so but without be focusing on
it's not a traditional exhausted
exertion techniques such as liquid
liquid extraction of protein
purification but I will try to encourage
you to consider micro extraction so this
would be very important for you to
understand the difference and advantages
so this is the example of to clearly
demonstrate days so here we have water
analysis and so typically what a nice if
you have one liter of water 40 meters of
solvent and basically then you separate
this do further with operations have a
concentration then you and you
concentrate to one milliliter and then
you inject one microliter out of this
into the uncle instrument it's a very
very lengthy process uses compares of
organic solvents and of course of
operations and what's happened with the
vapors of course goes to the atmosphere
which are venturing me brief so what I'm
saying is let's replace it with a much
simpler process you have an example
fiber coated with about 1 micro litre of
the extraction phase some type of
solvent and place it in the same amount
of 1 liter water now obvious some of you
says well you can do it but what about
the sensitivity of the measurements and
in fact if you go through the
calculation you find that the
sensitivity to be identical and why the
reason why is by trying to exhaustively
extract using 40 meters of solvent
you've actually lower the concentration
in water and therefore if you remember
from the previous slide when I show you
distribution constant the concentration
water is less so therefore the
concentration in the solvent is less as
well why here if you get a small amount
of extraction phase the concentration
what it doesn't change so your you
constitution of the fiber is much higher
so you have much high engagement factor
so this is one advantage so you have
kinder is my factor and the other event
says that you don't need to define the
volume because if you do exhaust
extraction you know the volume no the
chicken is exhausted extract right here
you basically place it in the source you
see we talked about tissue talked about
blood stream we talked about another
application binder application water and
so on so it's basically you don't need
to measure the volume of your sample
which is very convenient for on-site
analysis so this is the major reasons
why micro extraction gaining interest so
I will particularly focus on one form of
micro extraction called solid phase
microextraction and this is a technology
where the extraction phase is the
solvent which is dispersed on some type
of support and the amount of the solvent
is low so as I discussed before you
don't do exhausted extraction but she
rather extract and calibrated equilibria
Oh some kinetics factors like atropine
like I mentioned below and flow filter
flow injection analysis the beauty about
SPME is not only what I think is the
advantage of enrichment but it's also
you can coat any type of surface now so
you have a surface of the fibers you can
see surface of the two surveys of the
vessels particles stirring mechanism it
is can all of them has been already
investigated you see the publication
below which kind of introduces to now
those different topics quite early and
the previous slides you see the
references to the to the books which has
been published on the topic so
somebody's interested please consider
getting those books like in this here
you know you have another book now here
in practice so if you use a fiber format
which is the most popular one and but
it's not the only one which we use but
most of the application will show you
here will be fiber but also
the blades I'll show you in the moment
so basically you can consider three
different type of experiments they wreck
extraction so if you have a the first
slide from the left none so you have a
direct extraction clean matrix head
speaks extraction which is very powerful
application of the spinning Oh
more recently and that would have
focused on looking at the very complex
samples and using some type of membrane
protection approach to want the
contamination of the coating by real
matrices no they come as finished
commercially available primary while
looking at the foot analysis in
fragrance type of compounds but also in
clinical also application residue for
some solid residues drugs and has been
using headspace blood and so on so the
very complex matrix can be analyzed that
way because you isolate the sample from
the extraction phase ahead space so the
device which is very turquoise Pima
device and shown he is basically a
syringe where you have a coated fiber
inside the needle by moving the fiber in
and out you can expose the fiber to the
sample or you can protect it in the
needle now so if you extraction you
expose the fiber or if you examine
desorption spot the fiber anything
penetrate the stepped on you in the
fibrin and typical automated devices
city co2 simply which salt all over the
world this is another opportunity for
you to learn more there was a recent
paper anchor chemistry
published in January this year described
describing the recent developments the
technology you can see in the center you
see this range and they are different
approaches including the drone you can
see under water sampling doctors office
people centric michiga the human trials
now so it's basically a lot of different
opportunities
has this technology facilitate that so I
will tell you now about looking the
complex central because we'll be
focusing our presentation so as I
mentioned to you the very popular
application of six micro extraction the
headspace analysis as you can see in the
headspace analysis you separate the
extraction phase from the complex
samples your head space so anything good
which is volatile goes to the fibre
coating and enrich their the K value
discussable then you can take it out and
these are been local instruments get a
good clean extract because anything
which goes through the head PC screen to
be firmly dissolved in the auto-injector
of the GC and answering the comm
detected so well we have been working
for last 20 years to develop this the
RIC extraction so you can see below your
fiber placed directly in the matrix and
we wanted to also achieve this cleaner
approach so how did we do that so you
can see the matrix and the compounds
bound to the matrix they are in the
equilibrium with a free concentration of
the same analyte and now we are trying
to equilibrate the coating with this
free form so in fact anything which goes
they are free form to the coating and so
long as those matrix doesn't the matrix
shown here the proteins piece of tissue
do not answer on the fight but you have
a very clean extraction as well because
it goes we have three four this means it
is reasonably soluble in water so we can
dissolve it in the LC and incinerators
the solvent and introduce it to dancing
and basically perform the separations on
the clean matrix so here the example
will be benefit of that so you have a
Epica Majin end if you look on the left
slide and this is headspace
analysis 60 minutes extraction and
comprehensive dimension gas
chromatography and you can see that
compared to the right trace where you
have a gain to the initial
chromatography contains two initial gas
chromatography a vertical axis you have
a point boiling point and the horizontal
axis negative polarity so you actually
see much more compounds here on the
right side especially high molecular
weight and all the ones because those
have below andrey constant and therefore
they are not expected very well by
headspace approach so how do we now do
that
the cooperate is approach direct
extraction and clean extraction so
basically here it is shown what we do so
we basically have the fiber as you can
see in a part of the slide which is at
the coating the coating is surrounded by
the protection layer and this protection
layer as is shown below can consist of
the Teflon when to put your own neutral
Oh PDMS so if you have such a system
because of this protection layer nothing
is being absorbed on the surface of this
polymer so you have a clean extraction
so you just need to wrap it drains and I
wish King water enter from the
resorption now in addition this
technology works very well from
practical content producers are called
balanced coverage of fatal phobic and
hydrophilic compounds and the same time
this means we can extract compounds will
from different log P as long as the
soroban has high enough polarity to go
very deep Paula range so basically why
does it happen
so here it is like the mistake that you
have X you have this fiber whose
extraction finish
in addition around the fight exist so
called bond delay so it is the static
layer this exists in any type of system
placed in fluid or tissue so the in
order for the high molecules to go
through it takes a long time so within a
half an hour or so less when we perform
the same lingo blood extraction whatever
and those you know typically the fiber
if they reach it as I mentioned the
fiber is surface is impregnated with the
polymer which prevents it absorption so
by releasing it you can create the
Trudeau
meanwhile small molecules and those
Tucker points hydrophobic ones you can
see there are readily bound to the
matrix because of course I go for beacon
lights three concentrations very wrong
like hydrophilic as you can see very
poorly bound so three concentrations of
almost equal to the total concentration
and therefore as you put the fiber in
you miss equilibrate Tuesday with the
polar compounds and let me extract the
hydrophobic ones so within half an hour
you collect both very effectively and
here just to show you how does it work
so you compare the hydrophobic will try
to figure this you know morphine is
hydrophilic compound so you can see
there is no difference between
extraction of tanginess plasma plasma
contains the protein and pink yes not so
so basically you can see the
insemination to three equal total the
amount of extracted in both cases the
same Y in hydrophobic you can see huge
difference there's no protein to extract
no because in that case three equal
total
Y in when you have a protein some
binding occurs and therefore actually
might be seen much lower concentrations
so this is a mention to give you the
binding if you want to consider this
process more fully also need to consider
dissociation rate constant and so on
which we have done and so I feel kind of
recent publications which is actually
shown here the very brief summary what
this publication Tony
turning about it's basically showing
that because you have this balance
between the competing extraction by the
matrix compared to the partition on to
the fiber you actually extract the same
amount but roughly the same amount
independent of the log P of the compound
until of course the coating is not
capable to extract any more it means if
it's very polar you know because you
come from very polar or ionic will be
not extracted but have hydrophobic type
of extraction phase in a very polar one
so basically because of this competiting
by negative valence coverage and you can
extract range of compounds very
effectively and we evaluated at a number
of experiments here some of those
initial validations when you look at the
bacterial growth and - and we extracted
them number of experiments you can see
we published in June of metabolomics
what does it mean is basically the
storage very effective in extracting
full range of polarity of the compound
so you can actually get metabolomic the
tabular profile and the compound which
extract up from hundred two thousand now
you can do even more depending of the
porosity of this protection layer and
nandanam
as you can see we detect from - look if
you use a solvent such as will EJB
notable solvent we can detect it from
rock P - 17 the way to 15 so we see all
the compounds however because we
extracted the a free forum is a very
clean extraction so if you compare for
example our approaches came in which is
upper trace versus lower trace protein
precipitation you see you have an this
is a forty this is blank after forty
rounds of precipitation and after
is playing after 40 rounds of spme as
you can see below we have huge was fully
pink band come why in other or Apple
from other ground which is basically
multiplayer background the chromatic
below so it's basic hundred times more
sensitive the description so it's
basically you multiply the background by
hundred times and so you see you have
very very background here the spme
doesn't extract the huge amount of
phospholipids protein precipitation does
because we don't dissolve the
phospholipids you extract in tr3 form
but they sold ability so also expect
some of them to see them but not enough
because the travel okay so now from
practical point of view how do you use
this technology so the one of the
approach for high-throughput we are
using this device called concept 96
there's 96 blade system so instead of
coating fibers we actually coating place
to increase the surface area of the
solvent and therefore increasing mass
transfer to the extraction phase and
having as you can see four different
96-well plates one of it from the
oxidation the other one extraction and
rinsing and then desorption and then
this 96-well plate which unless
dissolved into it can go to the undercut
instrument now what's advantages of this
approach versus the SP
so basically the major one is because
it's open bed system now so it's
basically no particles of the tea
shaking the trunk there when SP
particular the sample food might occur
so that reasons why as I showed you
before there is no matrix that's like in
this technology you can do it all so
much
the easier automation is shown here and
we can look at the better amount of
samples without working on breakthrough
so there's several advantages and this
is well described in the literature now
more recently there was an improvement
this design and where you can see now
there's a tower which called 96-well
plate which I exchanged one by one so
first one was for the patient and
exchange it for extractions and
reasonings and desorption so such a
device it's less expensive so available
from company called PS technologies
interested now the other beautiful
feature of SP me as I mentioned the
beginning is because you can sample
directly from the source is an excellent
tool for in vivo spinning and the
primary reason for it is is because you
don't need to take the tissue out so we
call it chemical biopsy which we
equilibrate the coating with the system
and then I come taste and if you make
this coating in the form of coated fiber
so it could be very small you show
medium damage and you don't take any
tissue up you just take chemistry out so
Barbara will explore this approach
further give you some applications and
again the beauty about it is that when
you remove this chemistry out you also
isolate this chemistry from the enzymes
and therefore there's no enzymatic
degradation of the same to see in fact
in combining the extraction whose
quenching automatically and there is no
matrix aside so it's a very effective
tool so in summary what's why it's in
device kini is very first of all it's a
double
coverage of them small molecules is very
good eliminates suppression in mass
spectrometry measurement captures
unstable on lands
yes because you equilibrate with real
system and you can analyze immediately
after the extraction and then finally
because you are sampling the system is
an even damage for example if you do my
studies you can use one - oh the whole
pharmacokinetic profile without doing
much damage to the mines
this is improve the precision because
inter-annual variability is eliminated
here's the example so here one of the
our first studies and for those who are
interested you can look into the paper
which is listed below when we compare
standard approach on the right which is
the protein precipitation you know
standard approach and on the let you
gather - SPME approaches one is the
colibri one is pretty low so short-term
sampling long-term 75-minute verses two
minutes but you can see there is no
difference in the profile no difference
even in absolute balance so there is no
reason to do it direct to do traditional
methods where you actually need to draw
blood from animals and you can also do
tissues I think so we recently published
this paper and cut chemistry there are a
lot of the tensions you can see and
basically what it is as you can see
there are two devices principally which
we use in in the USP me one lower one
you can see tradition one we have a
fiber in the sheaf show unity phone and
then the upper part where you actually
have the coated needle with the coating
is in the in the
recess so because now we can make this
coating very robust so the tip penetrate
the tissue there is not much much shear
forces on the coating so we can reuse
this meeting many times so this is we
think this would be the ideal medical
device and we are working with number of
surgeons and any more persons in both
research important and Muslims and
finally what I want to see because
extraction is clean we don't need to
have chromatography can go directly to
mass spectrometry so this is really the
ideal well moving it everything on site
specially if you wanted to move it close
to the surgery room or even doctor's
office now so we can do it extractions
devices in the form of blades few beams
meshes fibers which we already discussed
and again this has been discussing this
review paper I mentioned to you and I
will not talk about in any more details
just in the king that this is
opportunity here I'll show you my group
the pollution also but I just wanted to
show what you see about this my website
while indicate to you because we
actually have the course is twice a year
and next one would be December 6 and 7
this year if you interested you can sign
up to actually experience their steamy
not only lectures but also in practice
where she got the practical experiment
finally there's also our conference
called xTag and the next year is going
to be in guangzhou china so again much
welcome to attend it if you found this
technology and interesting and
interesting to explore other extraction
technologies so now I give my space to
Barbara to continue the presentation so
hello everybody
now I will continue the talk by giving
you some more information about clinical
applications
and some other bio applications like
some cell line studies so basically
whatever Jung was talking about fits the
clinical purpose so as you can see here
spme as you already know is used in
headspace mode also in direct immersion
mode and it both applies to clinical or
bio applications so basically I will
focus on direct immersion headspace is
also used mainly for example for breath
analysis but also other analysis direct
immersion is more new because we have
right now biocompatible fibers and
thanks to that feature it allows us to
basically insert fiber directly into the
tissue or our blood so the workflow that
the an osha discussed with you also
applies here so as you can see after
extraction the fiber is quickly rinsed
and then it goes to organic solvent or
organic active solvent mixture and then
we basically injected this extract to
chromatograph couples to mass
spectrometer most of the cases so we are
using two basic devices two basic
geometries of spme the fiber which is
the main geometry that we are using for
tissue analysis because we want to
provide minimum invasiveness to the
system and then also so-called blades so
this is basically thin film to improve
the sensitivity but also this is very
common to be used in high throughput
mode and I will also show you some
examples of such applications so here I
just want to show you what are the
solutions of spme to the demands that
clinical applications have so first of
course we need to have very simple
method of sample collection ideally we
don't want to collect any sample if you
want to for example doing equal as you
explained it would be gray we don't want
to deal with too much samples so of
course here we can either take very
small amounts of the sample very small
volumes because so you have already seen
the fiber can be really small so the
extraction phase can be really very very
small so you don't really need to have
large volume of the sample or as I
mentioned if you have in vivo type of
application you don't collect any sample
you just extract small molecules of
Earth or other molecules if your
extraction phase is designed for that
from the system and then you basically
do not take out any sample so the second
demand is a simple analytical workflow
so if we really want to have a spin me
or any other technology in clinical lab
it cannot be very complex workflow we
want to have the least steps possible
and in fact spme is very simple so of
course it requires optimization there is
no magic here but it integrates the
sampling and sample preparation in one
step and if we also want to have
metabolism quenching for example if we
are looking for biomarkers we need to
quench metabolism immediately once we
collect the sample and here again if we
do in vivo then we have also quenching
integrated with two previous steps so
then it would be nice if we don't have
to have four different applications
different methods and I will show you a
number of examples here where we can use
spme and pretty much with the same
workflow so we can use the same
technology for many different
applications we can do target analysis
which is the most common for clinical
analysis but also we can do for example
research based also towards biomarkers
discoveries so we can do for example
metabolome profiling or lipid omics
analysis and another demand from
clinical point of view is application
for complex matrices whatever we
whatever matrix you deal with so pretty
much plasma urine see rooms who like a
whole blood or tissue these are really
complex matrices so as Young's mentioned
and also I already mentioned in in my
part we have already biocompatible
materials which we use for production of
the fibers and basically we don't
experience any matrix effect later on we
are eliminating large molecules from the
system and the matrix components they do
not attach to the fiber okay so another
two things which are necessary to be
opening the lab is hydro boot and
automation and in fact as Young's
already mentioned in his part we have
the automated system that basically
covers all steps in SPME workflow which
is reconditioning extraction wash
desorption and also on top of that we
can do have operation under Constitution
we also have an option to have a semi
automated system so we are just
replacing the 96-well plates but we
still have full control on the
temperature we have agitation of the
system and of course we have high truth
and then we go and we have high
sensitivity and wide dynamic range and
of course it was already mentioned we
have variety of solvents and geometries
you can play with so by increasing for
example volume of the solvent we have
the increased height increased
sensitivity so we have basically this
high sensitivity but we are dealing with
low concentrations and of course we can
also play with the time of our
extractions so we can work at the
equilibrium if we want to really reach
the highest possible concentration
I mean sensitivity or we can work at pre
equilibrium so then we actually have
much shorter extraction time but we
sacrifice sensitivity then a very
important thing is to sterilize the
fibre or the whatever device we are
using or to use them just a single time
and already from our experience we know
that we may autoclave the fibers we can
do basically regular out of we can do
regular sterilization without the
plating but we can also use for example
gas sterilization and of course alcohol
sterilization because in most of the
cases the pre conditioning is done in
the mixture of methanol water we may
want to also have temporal and special
resolution so for that we can of course
use the small fibers for example so we
can have number of sampling points just
by inserting the fibers at different
time points and we still have very low
invasiveness the size of the fiber the
dimension of the fiber is approximately
10 times lower than the acupuncture than
the biopsy needle so we can easily
repeat sampling of the same animal or of
the same organ a number of times of
course in the same time we can do number
of extractions so for example we can
have the same time point of extraction
and we can have simultaneous sampling of
different areas of the body we can have
fully quantitative method and we don't
have time today to play with
calibration and explain you all type of
calibrations we have but the answer
already mentioned a few so here we can
really choose from a variety of
different calibration approaches and we
can have fully quantitative data and I
will show example in a minute
of course we want to have results very
fast this is the first thing that
clinicians ask so how fast I can get the
data well of course if we are including
a Z run and usually a little bit long
but as you mentioned we can couple spme
directly with MS and then we are
actually hoping to have with the direct
coupling to have instrumentation on size
so pretty so give the data immediately
after sampling and of course it's very
important we don't want to have very
large organic solvents on side we don't
want to deal with organic solvents as
possible and this PME actually because
this is micro extraction technology we
basically have very minimum consumption
of organic solvents and if we have
direct acting with a mass it's actually
even less so now I will go through a few
examples of clinical applications the
first one is focused on oncology so
right now we are working on phenotyping
of brain tumors and we are working
towards intraoperative monitoring of
biomarkers so basically there are two
goals first is to propose a few
compounds which differentiate brain
tumors and they're great so we are
mainly focused on glioma
and the other one is to propose new fast
analytical approach to on-site
diagnostic testing of brain tumor so
that's what I already mentioned to
basically have very fast answer in the
operating room now here you can see how
we do sampling of tumors so these tumors
were just resected this is still in our
room
so we
inserting several fibers to the to the
two more on the left you can see my name
Yama's meningioma and on the right you
can see glioma so basically we chose
meningioma because this is I would say
easy two more to be sampled this day
resected usually as the whole two more
and this is very very easy to be
recognized by histological and testing
so basically we were using this tumor as
a reference so we were comparing our
data with histology on the right as I
said you can see glioma so this type of
tumor has many subtypes it's very
malignant tumors so this is the one that
we are interesting interested in to
basically find biomarkers of different
rates of biomass and also subtypes of
glioma which are susceptible for given
treatment or not on the next slide as
you can see we were optimizing the
method for this brain tumors so we were
testing different the sorption solvents
we have selected seven millimeter
coating for those fibers because this is
the optimum size that basically fit our
purpose and then we were running the
extracts using lc-ms but high resolution
mass spec you can see in the middle
figure is how many features we were able
to actually extract so you can see that
even with just seven millimeter fiber
and having our sampling we've been able
to obtain to extract hundreds of
hundreds of compounds and we always run
in hilly mode and rivers face mode just
to increase the coverage of analytes so
as you can see here they are basically
covering on each column from about
hundred to three hundred compounds then
you can see that we were very successful
in differentiating two different types
of tumors
basically biomass remaining Yama's I
don't have time to show you more data
today but we were also able to
differentiate different grades of tumors
and also when we compared with
histological and genotyping data our
phenotyping were actually in very good
agreement on the right you can see that
we are able to actually pick up
compounds of interest so compounds which
of course after running larger cohort
and after going through proper
validation we can actually propose some
potential biomarker for different tumor
types and different different malignancy
great so right now we are also focusing
on lipid omics because we want to extend
our studies to epidemic data and right
now we are already looking into the data
from more than 200 patients another
oncological project that we are involved
it's actually in collaboration with
Toronto General Hospital as monitoring
of doxorubicin this is the drug which
was used for high dose local
chemotherapy so basically that was
animal study so as you can see here that
was peak model in our collaborators the
clinicians they were actually looking
into the concentration and distribution
of this drug in the lung so different
lobes of the lung because they are
working on new methods of drug delivery
so basically were using the perfusion
system to deliver this particular chemo
therapeutic agents to the lung tissue
where the tumor is located so basically
the lungs are isolated from the rest of
the body so the chemotherapeutic agent
shouldn't actually go into different
parts of the body so the problem that
the clinicians had who was basically how
we
the concentration of the drug because
they cannot do that many biopsies over
the period of this perfusion so we were
basically inserting the fiber through
the lung as you can see here and the
arrow points actually into three fibers
located in one of the lobes of the lung
this is not the left side of the picture
and on the right you can see exactly the
same spot after sampling so as you can
see actually the the method is not
really invasive there is no bleeding
there are just air bubbles coming out
but you know basically we were we were
repeating the same procedure number of
times so we will see the results in a
moment of course again this is the
targeted method requires optimization so
we were looking into the effect of
autoclaving so basically autoclaving
even improved the effectiveness of the
extraction we are also testing different
reconditioning solvents and what is very
important we of course here need to do
calibration so as I mentioned we will
not go into details but here I just
mentioned we were we were using external
calibration so as a surrogate matrix you
are using a lamp line and we homogenized
this matrix and basically we were
spiking at different concentrations of
the doxorubicin and we were extracting
exactly using the same extraction time
and as you can see on the bottom right
picture we were comparing the results
from the tissue collected in the
hospital so first we were extracting
from this intact tissue and then we
homogenized the same tissue and we
extract from this homogenate and we were
getting exactly the same data and using
the calibration curve prepared in this
rotate matrix so then with this method
of course were fully validated so you
can see the result we meet all the
requirements and then you can see
basically the results of during the
perfusion how the concentration and
distribution of the drug was changing so
the clinicians were using two different
those of the drug you can see first it
was increasing ten at some point the
drug concentration was dropping so as
you can see we can get fully
quantitative data using in vivo
extraction and for calibration using
external calibration curve of course in
vivo solid-phase microextraction was
used for many other studies here you can
see how we are doing extraction from the
circulatory system from the blood system
you can use either this needle SM with
fibers so you can insert them directly
to the vein of the animal and then
expose the fibers to the blood stream
for the extraction
or you can also place this fiber through
the catheter which is standard for
clinical application you can also insert
the non assembly fiber through the lower
log type of designs and so it's very
flexible method as you can see you can
just adjust it to your knee so basically
you can tailor your method to your needs
and to the environment you need to work
with in terms of rodent studies of
course such fibers specially assembly
fiber is to be to be inserted directly
to the vein of the animal so in that
case you basically use one of the
interfaces that was developed for the
purpose so here you can see that there
are basically different designs one
which is in the middle this is basically
the interface which is like a loop so
one end is inserted into one brain of
the animal and then the other end it
goes back to the animal so the blood
circulates through this interface so you
can basically insert the fiber
and to this interface and you can also
lose for example saving for other pump
to provide some agitation by using
push-pull type of agitation and then on
the right you can see that also this
type of device can be one way so again
you can use the push/pull with syringe
for example to agitate the blood through
the device and then you can sample as it
is shown on the picture so again some
examples of the applications so exactly
these devices were used for extraction
from the bloodstream of carbamazepine
and its metabolite
so basically the colleague of mine was
using full pharmacokinetic profiling
pharmacokinetic profile of carbamazepine
and it's metabolite and it was the spme
data was compared with automated serial
sampling and also terminal blood draw so
for those of you who are not familiar
with the technologies basically for this
kind of studies pharmacokinetic analysis
you really need to use number of animals
so you either sacrifice one animal per
data point that's for the terminal and
or you can basically take a volume of
blood but then the animal needs to
recover for some time to be used for
next sampling so as you can see here
basically the number of animals needs to
be quite large to get this full
pharmacokinetic profile as shown on the
picture and if you look carefully into
the data SPME gives the same results but
RSD is actually a lot lower for SPME
because as the answer already mentioned
we are actually eliminating inter-annual
variability here so first we don't
sacrifice as many animals and the other
one we are improving the data by
eliminating inter animal or me
animal variability we are not limited to
blood on that picture you can see that
we are also using thermal kinetic
profiling of carbamazepine but from the
rat brain and for this type of studies
we are also using micro dialysis for
comparison because this is basically a
gold standard I would say for brain
studies and as you can see again the
data was in full agreement between the
two methods we are not limited to drugs
absolutely we can also do endogenous
compounds so this is the example of the
targeted metabolomics so as you can see
here a colleague of mine he was actually
looking into different neurotransmitters
during drug stimulation so again
comparison of micro dialysis showed a
very good agreement but in fact he was
interested in for neurotransmitters but
because of low sensitivity of micro
dialysis we were only seeing we only
seen two neurotransmitters with micro
dialysis but as PME allowed us to see
all four of them but this point the fact
that we have seen two again you can see
that the data is in full agreement
between the tomatoes and while we
already had the the extract from from
the targeted analysis we we thought that
it would be good to actually check how
the untargeted metabolomics look like
when we compare spme and micro dialysis
and as you can see from that table and
the graph there was number of compound
that actually changed over the time
after the drug stimulation and of course
there was a huge difference between
micro dialysis and spme in terms of
coverage because micro dialysis is
basically the method used for polar
compounds so non polar compounds are not
going to the Diana
but for SPME actually we had much better
coverage for for nonpolar compounds and
slightly less for the all our compounds
comparing to micro dialysis so basically
these two method can be nicely used
together giving us a very very broad
coverage of analytes and then I will go
to the next project that we have done
now as you can see we were using this
high-throughput and automated system so
basically we were looking into the first
pharmacokinetic of two drugs tranexamic
acid and rocuronium bromide in the
patients who received a liver graft and
we had two groups first was heart
beating donors and the other one living
donors so basically especially for
rocuronium we were checking if this drug
can be used a marker of only grab
dysfunction because the dead donor so
basically heart beating donor groups as
supposed to have worst metabolism of the
drug because the drug is mainly
metabolized by Liebherr and in fact we
were we were right so basically this
drug can be potentially used as a marker
of early liver dysfunction but we also
looked into the global profile of the
patient so we were using exactly the
same system for doing targeted and
untargeted analysis because for this
type of of analysis you need to have
really quite a large group so we just
focus on targeted profiles we just took
a part of the patients samples and we
just check if we have any type of
separation as you can see here we were
able to differentiate between the two
groups and also pick up some compounds
which differentiated this two group so
of course after again running the larger
cohort if we confirm those compounds can
be potentially used as biomarkers of
early liver dysfunction
when we are talking about high
throughput system especially in 96 96
plates
well plays we can also think about
different in vitro assays related to
cell culturing so here also we are using
this system that I showed you previously
the fully automated system and also a
semi automated system for doing cell
line analysis well usually we culture
cell lines or doing any type of for
example my person essays in 96-well
format and this is also fully compatible
with the device that we showed you
previously so here for example you can
see that we can use this 96-well plates
for culturing the cells and then doing
time calls analysis so basically using
the same samples for number of times for
extraction of number of times and then
we can get time course analysis so we
can observe what compounds are declining
and what compounds are appearing in the
system so for example here we were
observing the impact of drag first we
were extracting from just from the
cancer cells and then we expose them to
the drug and we were observing changes
over the period of time exactly from the
same wells the standard methods for the
standard methods you basically need to
stop metabolism and you cannot reuse the
same sample you need to basically have
number of samples for the experiments if
you want to look over the period of time
here we can decrease number of samples
and reuse the same samples for different
time point analysis also this 96-well
format as I mentioned it useful for
example microsomal heiresses so here we
were looking into the metabolism of the
dragon brightest at Anuj it's fairly new
drug and so far there is just a few
metabolites known so we've been using
this time course analysis with SPM
to figure out what compounds what new
compounds are coming up when we
basically incubate drug with the
microsomes we compare this data with
electrochemical metabolic detection and
then we verified with in silico
prediction and as you can see we've been
able to increase the number of
metabolites from 5 to 16 with the
proposed approach so basically to sum up
you can see that this beam is very
flexible technology it can be used in a
high throughput mode and it can be used
in just the fiber mode to have very low
invasive sampling so you can easily
sample very complex matrices including
tissues you can get very nice and broad
analyte coverage the method is very mini
moving basically if you use just as tiny
fiber which is basically the acupuncture
needle size then you can have the time
course analysis if you want to perform
some extraction from either for example
tissue without damaging the system or
for example you may minimize the number
of samples and still have full and full
idea about the changes over the period
of time method is fully quantitative as
so as I said there is number of
calibration methods that you can use for
that and you can specially use them for
different clinical but also medical
research type of application in I prefer
actually this method for tissue analysis
over the over the traditional method
because we are actually having here true
snapshot of the metabolism when we do in
vivo studies versus homogenized studies
you can do cell culturing with your
traditional 96 plate system a digital
plate system
you can basically reuse the same sample
and even at the end you can perform
traditional essays on the same samples
and of course if we couple spme directly
with mass spect or other instrumentation
we can provide our clinicians with
intraoperative rapid diagnostic tool in
the near future
and i also want to acknowledge all my
students also Yanis group of course our
collaborators and our sponsors who are
providing us so if the instrumentation
and the spme devices thank you very much
for your attention
thank you dr. Boyko and dr. population
for that informative presentation we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speakers will follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started the first question is why
did solid-phase microextraction
technology not find its way to general
use in clinical laboratories yet groups
that are using the technology and fairly
new in bio applications but basically we
can see that for the last four five
years the interest is really growing so
clinicians are really happy with the
technology so we basically work with
many groups especially surgeons but not
only but I think that well right now
there is the only one one company which
provides the bio compact
fibers so that might be one of the of
the problems but I think that also
people are they do not treat sample
preparation as a science so they are
very focus Peschel e in medical area
they're very much focused on the
traditional methods so I think that this
is one of the problems that basically
the medical area is it's very difficult
to go through with some new things and
SPM is definitely one of such things but
I can see from our experience that
actually more and more people interested
so I hope that in the nearest future it
will be much more people but many many
people are using that much more than
today thank you for that next one is
what is the future of the spme
technology yes basically future is
bright the issue is it's a new kid on
the block
so in fact it's kind of related to the
previous question anything could you
looks very difficult now because the
device is different the precision little
different calculations and somewhat
different in some cases so the photo
preservation however the format is so
stable that it can actually potentially
solve a lot of problems so example just
came the idea one of the futures see
that pictures drawn is that actually
connect patients inverter solution
remote places into the center labs and
so so basically the devices are so light
because they actually enrich the central
even a small volume maximal fiber or
some place to use measures you can then
easy transport etcetera now there's a
remote community
a little Canada oftentimes you know the
issues for writing the sisters
in addition to lecture because using
thank you for that next one is is
saturation of the coding a problem yes I
mentioned that my part of my
presentation that because we have this
notion of expression we are reform and
reform of analytes is controlled by the
sort of data value lines in the
compounds which are hydrophobic which
actually has a tumor solubility in
thickness matrix which is most of the
that will constitute
basically when I talk to a lot of
scientists because of the paradigm is
what I think this was the first picture
I show because noticing such a smooth
lines if someone has a compound think
you do so much damage to their but I
take the dog and in fact if they dig
will die because a lot of systems whey
proteins which carry the analyzing such
other analyzed because to do that so
placing the five bit cool agrees with
this system but it because the
communication occurs the are three from
liquids mean yeah the situation it
appears because the compounds which can
essentially be very sort of what sort of
extensions to be so so was in time
section
thank you looks like we have time for
just one more question
how its solid phase microextraction
calibrated yeah so this is one of the
standard blog because that you say well
how do you calibrate the process which
is completely different exhaustive
extraction
not expecting become foliage so you take
one little one me little flat and then
whatever you extracted from this one
liquor and you divide by the
concentration here it's a little bit
different so basically you need to
develop a calibration profile called
matrix nice calibration that's just
basically same things what we are doing
even exhaustively because the issue had
a complex matrix you still validate
exhaustive Cary Grant's do the same
thing the same thing to calibrate
basically in essence find the K value or
some other parameter and based on that
we can calibrate learn there's also a
very interesting way of calibrating
called Cary Grant in the construction
field because the Andalites only Oh in
that case in actually came category such
a conviction condition that's because
when you have done extraction phase
would contact with matrix multiply next
attractive depending on the condition
traditions take the concentration
Lincoln ratio just convection as I said
in a sense they are very similar
calculation approaches at the
traditional methods but they are
somewhat different electrolyte so this
mainly looking challenging this
information of course will take some
time to acquire so I strongly encourage
those who fantastic
as soon as you can see it's very useful
[Music]
analysis as well as in vivo those want
to know about that time coming for the
course is a mission in Waterloo we are
organizing the course it was the year
thank you
I would like to once again thank dr.
Boyko and dr. Pavel yishun for their
presentations I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I'd like
to remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January 25th 2019 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that is all for now thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye